-Welcome back.
-Well, thank you, Seth.
-Thank you for finding --
-Straight from Iowa.
-Yes.
-You had a debate last night
It was the smallest debate
the seventh debate,
the first one
with only six people.
Has it been -- I mean, It must
be strange, in some ways,
because some of the people
who have dropped out
are colleagues of yours.
-I miss my friends,
especially Kamala and Cory
-But is it also nicer to hav
a little bit more real estat
over the course
of two hours of the debate
-Yeah. You got more room.
You know, emotions read.
You don't run into Bernie,
you know?
-But it is -- No, it's goo
and it really gives me
the chance to show, really
three things.
One, optimistic economic agend
for this country,
given what this president does
every single day,
where he brings people down.
And the second thing -- that
you're tough enough to beat him.
Check. And I think
the debates --
The debates actually --
the debates give you
that opportunity,
because they see
you interact with other
candidates.
And the third thing is tha
you can win,
because that is
the one thing that unites
our party more than any.
And I -- The case that
I have been making
is that a lot of people ar
talking about it,
but when you look at
my record, they say,
"Women often run
on their record,
and men run on their potential."
And, in my case, I have wo
every single race every time
in all of those Trump counties
that we need to win,
bringing in rural, suburban.
And, in fact, my last
three Republican opponents
have all gotten out of
politics for good.
And I think, given the guy
in The White House,
that sounds pretty nice.
-There was a situation
last night --
I was getting ready to watch
the debate at 9:00,
here on the East Coast,
and at around 7:00, 7:30,
this Giuliani/Lev Parnas
news breaks.
So, this situation --
Obviously, you're prepping
The other candidates onstage
are prepping.
You're probably not even aware
this is happening.
And then, in the sort of moments
after the debate,
the news has to balance both
talking about this
and talking about that.
Is it frustrating to you
how quickly the news cycle
moves on from what happens
over the course of
a fairly substantive
discussion of issues
that happened on the stage
last night?
-To pick the president, yes.
-Yeah.
-And you would like that debat
and the moments from the debat
to be captured,
but this is what it's like
in the era of Donald Trump
Day after day after day,
things come up,
and I think it is up to us
to make our own case
and to not allow everyone
to be distracted.
And there will be
those moments where people
are going to focus on
this primary.
It will happen.
It's happening right now
in the early states.
But given that, we've got
a really important thing
happening right now,
and that is
the impeachment trial
that I'm going back to tonight
-Yes. So, here's another
crazy thing you have to balance,
which is running for president
while, at the same time,
being a senator, while, at
the same time, being a juror
in this trial that's basically
going to take place.
This new information was
about Marie Yovanovitch,
who was a former ambassado
to Ukraine.
You actually -- You know her
-Yes, quite well.
-What year is this trip?
-Okay, this was right afte
Donald Trump got elected.
And that is Senator McCain
who I miss very much,
who was a good friend,
and Senator Graham
and then Marie Yovanovitch, then
the ambassador, and me.
You notice my outfit.
I thought I would try to
fit in in camouflage.
-Yeah. Right.
-We were actually on
the front line.
And that's the former president.
We were on the front line.
And Ambassador Yovanovitch
I note,
was this lovely, lovely host
and Senator McCain
respected her so much.
And, so, when I saw her testif
and saw the things
the president was
saying about her,
much less the latest news
we have now,
where there's people
literally trying to,
at the very least,
surveil on her.
and spy on her
and who knows what else,
to me, it's a travesty.
This is a career public servan
who has done nothing
but sacrifice for our country.
And so I hope we remember that
that's what this is about.
It's about our country,
people that have put their lives
on the line, whether in
the military
or in the diplomatic corps
And we need a president
that puts our country first,
that doesn't put their
private interests
or their partisan interest
in front of the interests
of our country.
-You -- All that I agree with.
I think the real question is -
You know, it's been --
It's been basically a mont
since the article --
since the president
was impeached.
And there was some talk abou
the hesitation to actually
send it to the Senate.
And in those 30 days,
as with every 30 days
in the Trump presidency, so much
more information has come out.
Now we're going into this tria
with this Yovanovitch
information.
Do you think that will move or
convince or change
the minds of any of your
colleagues across the aisle?
-Well, I hope so.
And all we are asking for
right now is four witnesses.
Richard Nixon allowed all th
president's men to testify
We're simply asking
for people who have
firsthand knowledge --
John Bolton,
who actually has said
he wants to testify,
Mick Mulvaney,
who is the president's
acting Chief of Staff,
who's the one that made
the front-line decision
to hold up the aid
to this fledgling democracy,
and then two others,
one of whom has sent these
smoking-gun e-mails.
It is crazy that they won'
allow them to testify.
And as I said last night
at the debate,
if they're not going to allo
these witnesses
that the president claims
exonerates him,
they may as well give him
a scepter and a crown
and let him be the king
And last time I checked,
in America,
the president is not king.
The law is king.
-Yes, usually...
[ Cheers and applause ]